Hello everyone. Before we go ahead and
get on into the video, I just wanted to
say that I am still doing bond giveaways
up until the end of the month. So, if
you guys want to be entered into any of
those, basically all you have to do is
comment your RSN on a video of mine that
I upload between now and the end of the
month. On top of that, like the video
and subscribe as well. As far as the
last video, the winner of that giveaway
was RS Money Guy 36. So, congratulations
to you, man. Good luck with the rebuild
as well. But, let's go ahead and get on
into the video. So, in today's video,
I'll be showing you guys a money-making
method that is just it's it's a really
strange and kind of out of the way
technique that no one would ever think
of. Luckily enough for me, one of my
friends yesterday, his name is Hardcore
Suty. Let me find it real quick. Yeah.
Yeah. Sweat Bag's always online. There
he is. So, uh, feel free to follow him
at Twitter. I'll give him a shout out.
He probably isn't the first person to
figure this out, I'm sure. I mean, it's
just common knowledge, but he was the
person that actually told me about this
method. So, as far as requirements,
you're going to need as much cash as
humanly possible. For each ALK that
you'll be doing, you'll need 45k. Uh
granted you'll be I mean alking so
you'll be getting cash back and then you
can buy just as soon as you're done but
uh the more that you're able to buy the
easier it makes it I guess. So basically
as far as requirements as I said just
cash and the ability to use high alk so
55 magic and just some nature runes and
fire runes as well. Uh basically right
now I have all of these stuff bought
currently and here they are. So
bracelets of Ethereum. So you want to
buy these I guess you can only buy these
uncharged but the main point is they're
uncharged. They're 14 or at least in
this case 42.9K.
Now, you may be able to actually buy
them or sell them for a little less.
Let's go ahead and see what one sells
for right now. So, 43K on the dot. So, I
got a little lucky that I ended up
buying them a little earlier. So, 42.9K
each. Now, if we do an examine, uh, the
OS buddy guide price should tell us,
yeah, the high elk is 43.2K. So, even
right now, I mean, assuming a nature 200
GP, I'm I'm making 100 GP by alking
them, which is pretty crazy alone. But
on top of that, they have a really high
GE value, so you can buy a decent amount
of them at a time. But the real kicker
is right here. So, let me grab one of
these real quick. As you guys can see,
the regular bracelets, while it doesn't
show their ALK price here, I'll go ahead
and alk one for you guys. Actually, ALKs
for 45K on the dot. And as you guys just
saw a second ago, I was buying the
bracelets for 42.9K. That's a 2.1K
margin, but there is something you have
to do. You can't just go ahead and stack
them all. Basically, they do have to be
charged, and they only really need one
platinum token in them. So, if I just go
like this, it's charged. and then I can
alk it and that is a profit of I mean 2K
almost. The overall difference between
the price of the bracelet at 42.9K and
the high al value of 45k is 2.1k and
each time that you end up casting this
you'll be using a nature rune which is
200 GP and you'll also be adding in a
revenant ether every time. That's what
these are. That's what charges the
bracelets. So one of these is 170.
Nature runes also 200 GP. So really your
margins are more around 1,700 to 1800 GP
per alk. but it definitely is something
that is really just kind of weird to do
and it does get you a little bit of
magic XP as far as the setup and what
you're going to need. Basically, you'll
only need a fire staff as far as what
equipment you're going to want to wear.
Uh you can use any sort of fire staff or
you could use a tome of fire just to be
able to have infinite law runes and then
on top of that a rune pouch. Doesn't
really matter. You can just have nature
runes as well. At some point you're
going to have coins in your inventory.
So I just stack them up along with the
bracelets as well. Uh every time I
actually start to do another trip I go
ahead and use these on the bank. Then I
unnote. And then you bank bank one of
these and take out one. So pretty much
this is what you're going to want to do.
I'll just talk real quick while I do it.
Something that I do is I put these in
the bottom right hand corner. You could
also have a screen marker to kind of
make it a little easier to see. And
typically I have it so that it's down
here so that every time I don't have to
go all the way down here. It's just kind
of somewhat close in the middle. So
yeah, just all you have to do really is
just open your bank, charge one, open
your bank, charge one. And it's pretty
simple to do. So I'm going to go ahead
and do this entire inventory and then
I'll come back to you. Now, a couple
things I'll go ahead and mention real
quick and just some mistakes you can end
up making doing this. Basically, uh,
make sure to kind of keep an eye on
which one of these is actually charged
and which one isn't. It's really hard to
tell. I mean, you can tell in a sense,
but once they all kind of become charged
or uncharged, then it becomes a little
harder. And so, if you end up putting
another piece of Revenant ether in
there, that is going to obviously be
another 170 GP that you're going to
lose. Not a big deal, but it will affect
you in the long run. Another thing I
want to mention is make sure to be
wearing a bracelet of Ethereum. Um,
depending on what your high al price is
set to, you may end up alking something.
Earlier, I accidentally ended up wearing
a bracelet and then alking my Barrows
glove. So, not really a big deal, but
just something to keep an eye out for.
On top of that, if you get a warning
every time that you are outing one of
these that's too high of a price, just
come over here to the high alk spell and
then do set warning value and just set
it above 50k and then you'll be good to
go. But yeah, once you do an entire
inventory, basically you're going to
want to go ahead and just high alk them.
Now, you cannot bank these. You can in a
sense, but you have to pull them out of
your bank unnoted. So, it's not going to
help. And whenever you put them in a
bank, each individual bracelet takes up
its own slot no matter the amount of
charges on it. So, there's really no way
to stack these. So, you're just going to
want to high elk them after you get done
with each inventory. Overall, for my
testing earlier, what I was able to find
was that each inventory took about 2 1/2
minutes and then the amount of money
that you made in that time was about 44
45K depending on the margins that you
found on the bracelets. On top of that,
the magic XP per hour was lingering
somewhere around 40,000, but that's just
some estimated rates. I'm going to go
ahead now and do an hour of this and see
how much I'm able to make and how much
magic XP I'm able to get. Probably won't
be too much since, you know, high alking
regularly tops out at like 70k, but
it'll be a little bit of side XP for
anyone that wants it. So, here we are.
These are the hourly results. I was able
to out 652 bracelets within an hour. And
overall, what this really comes out to
is your total cash, I guess, for what we
actually invested initially. We put in
27 mil 978K.
So that's going to be the cost of the
bracelets that we ended up paying for.
Then we're going to have to add the
natures and the revenue ether as well.
And in total that's 28.2 mil. Now if we
go ahead and see what our total cash
stack is, it's 29.34
mil, which means overall it's over 1.1
mil per hour. And it's definitely I mean
it's all right. As far as mage XP goes,
you're doing 652 high outcasts per hour.
So that's 42.5k. It's not great.
Obviously, if you're trying to train
magic, there are other better ways and
more efficient ways to go about it. But
if you want to do a good money-making
method and get some XP on the side, it's
definitely a good way to go about it.
So, hopefully you guys enjoyed the video
and can use this at some point in the
future. It should be a pretty good
money-making method considering
bracelets have come into the game so
quickly that their price literally went
all the way to ALP price within a couple
weeks. So, hopefully these bracelets
will stay profitable for you guys and
you guys will be able to make a little
bit of money. As far as the video goes,
make sure to leave a like and a comment
down below if you guys still want to be
entered into the bond giveaway. And on
top of that, if you guys enjoy my
content, just make sure to subscribe
for, you know, just the fun of it, you
know. Hopefully you guys enjoyed the
video and found it helpful. But with
that said, hopefully you guys have a
wonderful day
[Applause]